και ότον το πράγμα πρά το εύκαλε πρόεδοα οφονάξεν των ισύμβουλάτορες του ελαρούσαν το α
σε κρούσει τορναρίδη ύμως τς αρφώς ήταν το α νδαλμα το απο κιονται ημέρας αλλά
και καταλάβουν ότι ξέει τον τοτ συμτών το ριβέρα όλοκκαιτούτα τα πράγματα που ξ που
κνο καιας πούμελοιπόν και πί ε επίνοοτο δουλίδι στην τελευταία μέρα στον τιπέει και μιλούσα
για τόν το πράμα ττκαι νομίσαν ότι ανον του κακό ενώτι θέατω του κανγκακό φννα
τους πολς ττ μαζίτ τυ α το κατάλαβες ναι κτός που τονικο χριστόδουλίδη ίσουν δίπλα
και που το φδι ακριβώ μιλούμε αρκετά βείται αρκετά πράματα δίπλαβοφια το τελευταίο διάστημα όμως
έχαθήκαν τα τάβιτ υπάρχει σχέσι με το φυία μιλάτε ή επιες το ευροκινοβουλίο και ν
υπάρχει σχέσ μοχριστόβνώ τωατξ ήταν φευράρεπιασα ένα μήνυμα θέλωσεπότκασφιδίας μο του το ρεγώμέκτα στο βουνό
ναι ένα δεν τηλεφονο που που παντού σήμεα τώρα που μετα έ υτά προς κλησε
και παπό αφοόταν βάλω ένα στόρι αβαλωκτε πιαν το παραάνο βγιούς που τα που τοτούτα
που γανετε λεσίς μέγανισμου χαίνπιεξέμε βουοπό πάωσίγουρα πάω και καποκένα σου τοπέ το καλλά τα
απόφεύγοτο ς πούμε είιείπατο στα παιθκά μου άναία μου παπάπρια πάεισ ενώφιδασ ιόλα μάσκιτυποσιαστικα καιξέχει
ποιο υτοκινμ είπεπα στο τρόδος παράλαβε με που το εσταία τώρο το αυταίον του ξημαρισάλοιπόν
καιτσχάμαμε ένα κασοραίο μαζί θαύκοντας είμε μου είσι ποιο ξιμος άνθρωπος της κύπρου σαν εσέναν
έ εξα ποτέ μου ποτούτα από κνα και ά λοιπόν να με βοηθήσεις να τογασο
πω επλέτα στο αυτο γίνητο στην τηλώρασηαλοτου θα σε χθα σε υκάλω ευρο βουλευτί υπάσουν
πριν ότι ότι νι να πω κάμνωτο ενέχει αποκάθηκαμε γίνει ότι ότι εντούτο θα υρωτρό
να το κμω είναιδιγότητο επίασε πέρασα πιοτρεις ημέρας πιντημάνηκαέπληείναι με τοαολουγάνικο μετούς επλήνες κατα αυτογίνητο
του